11 novembre 1918 les français laissent
exploser leur joie
c'est l'armistice la première guerre
mondiale prend fin mais le coup est
immense un million quatre cent mille
français meurent dans les tranchées pour
leur rendre hommage
le parlement décide en 1920 d'honorer la
tombe d'un soldat non identifié un toit
lui doit choisir parmi huit dépouilles
celle qui deviendra le symbole du
recueillement national le soldat inconnu
m'a remis un bouquet en me disant
cercueil sur lequel vous déposerez ce
bouquet lui sous l'arc de triomphe pour
immortaliser tous les morts de la guerre
le cercueil retenu est exposée sous
l'arc de triomphe à partir du 11
novembre 1920 et la commémoration des
morts se transforme vite en rituel
républicain à certaines occasions
l'hommage aux poilus trouve même une
résonance toute particulière comme à la
libération par exemple général de gaulle
et monsieur winston churchill s'incline
devant la dalle le soldat inconnu amont
et pendant les quatre ans de notre
humiliation à gages est réelle mais
vigilant la symbolique du soldat inconnu
est renforcée par cette flamme éternelle
une image dont se sert le général de
gaulle pour célébrer la grandeur de la
france lors d'un discours aux invalides
le 10 novembre 1968 créer cette même
flamme qui inspirera au long de la vie
comme elle l'a fait au long du passé la
france célébrée la france victorieuse
est célébrée aussi ses alliés au premier
rang desquels le royaume uni les onze
novembre 1988 et 1998
le prince charles et la reine
d'angleterre seront les invités des
présidents mitterrand et chirac
les gestes de recueillement sont
toujours les mêmes
mais en 2007 le président sarkozy
bouscule la tradition devant la tombe du
soldat inconnu
il prononce pour la première fois un
discours plaidant pour un avenir de paix
un avenir de fraternité entre les
nations
cet avenir nous lui avons donné un nom
l'europe ne l'oublions jamais nicolas
sarkozy concrétise ce discours en 2009
pour la première fois ils invitent un
chef de gouvernement allemand a
participé aux célébrations du 11
novembre
temps fort de ce moment historique
l'hymne allemand et jouer après la
marseillaise
[Musique]
en 2011 après la disparition du dernier
poilu
nicolas sarkozy propose de rendre
hommage non plus uniquement aux
combattants morts pendant la première
guerre mondiale mais à tous les soldats
morts pour la france comme ses 24
soldats tombés en afghanistan entre 2010
et 2011
[Musique]